hi welcome back
wait what hi I'm not Simon Park you
might recognize me from places such as
not being the author of firmament the
hidden science of whether climate change
in the air that surrounds us
that case tackles nah but they both do
maths have very funky hair and very
similar names I'm Kat a maths PhD at the
University of bath studying fluid
dynamics pan-acidental I also stream on
Twitch in my spare time doing mass
communication and sharing my experience
of being a PhD student I often go on
tangents on stream about topics that I'm
passionate about and just like everyone
else those opinions can be completely
baseless done mostly on Vibes and very
difficult to change my mind about
obviously I'm going to share some of
those opinions with you now specifically
I'm going to talk about my field of
research if Simon can rank clouds I can
definitely rank fluid dynamics fluid
dynamics is the study of flows of fluid
meaning liquids or gases under forces or
stresses which can cause them to move
the behavior of the fluids can vary due
to a wild variety of factors how viscous
the fluid is meaning how much it sticks
to itself how dense the fluid is what
type of fluid is it are there multiple
fluids interacting with each other or is
there a boundary around there acting on
the system even just what extra forces
are there like gravity when all these
different factors combine in different
ways the the fluids can behave wildly
differently and some of the resulting
flows are incredibly cool and some of
them are meh without further Ado I
introduce you to the fluid Dynamic
phenomena tier list we're going from F
tier all the way to EST here judging
will be done on Vibes sci-fi nurse and
mathematical Beauty I study bouncing
droplets now when a droplet is Falling
Towards a liquid bath one of three
things is going to happen it's either
gonna Splash it's gonna sit on the
surface and coalesce meaning it touches
and disappears or and this is the cool
one it's gonna bounce when it bounces it
means that the speed and size is right
so that their layer of air keeping the
two liquids apart doesn't deplete
doesn't disappear it prevents the
droplet from touching the free surface
so the free surface has time to kick
backwards and basically act like a
trampoline now you can start getting
really funky with changing the size and
the speed of the droplets so that
splashes cause bouncing droplets or
coalescing causes Cascades or smaller
and smaller bouncing drops if you shake
the bath itself you can get periodic
droplets that will bounce indefinitely
and if you want to know more about those
go check out the PHD stories video I did
with Simon last year so where am I
ranking this well it's not just because
it's my PhD research it's also because
rain bouncing on puddles is one of the
best Moody Aesthetics and one of the
reasons why anime looks so pretty
sometimes so I'm putting this in Nest
here so what about the simplest fluid
flow when all the fluid streamlines
meaning the directions of the velocities
all point in the same direction or are
parallel to each other or anti-parallel
they're very neatly organized this is
called laminar flow this phenomena is so
smooth that when a jet of it moves
through air it can look like glass it
looks so still now it's really pretty
and it's a fun experiment to try and
recreate at home but it's kind of boring
but without it us mathematicians would
be screwed we oftentimes use laminar
flow assumptions for systems to be
easier than when we consider them
without it we'd have to look at every
single particle and how that moves in
the fluid and that's just just way too
much a good phenomena to have but it's
pretty meh so seating what about that
messy non-laminous stuff turbulence is
perhaps a more accurate model of what
happens all around us streamlines
interact and the movements become
chaotic and unpredictable this can look
really pretty however the mathematician
in me is screaming because turbulence is
often where a lot of our current models
will break down you really need heavy
machinery like either scientific
computations or experiments to
understand turbulent flow and all of my
assumptions especially completely stop
working so turbulence can get in the bin
left here laminar and turbulent flows
are the two extremes of fluid dynamics
and often the building blocks for a lot
of the other phenomena we're going to
look at the next few phenomena to make
the list occur when fluid interacts with
very particular boundaries so let's get
back into it perhaps one of the
prettiest phenomena I'm going to show
you next can often be hard to see damn
you turbulence these are Von Carmen
Vortex streets these are caused by
what's called Vortex shedding when a
uniform flow moves past a solid body the
flow left in the wake after the body is
often unsteady and gets pushed from side
to side generating these beautiful
vortices that align themselves in these
periodic patterns and they're compared
to lampposts down a street thus the the
name for Aesthetics I'm giving this B to
you what if instead we move to something
3D instead of just one direction of
rotation we expand to a Taurus like a
donut shape so the flow is rotating
around the cylindry bit of the donut
this is called a Vortex ring they occur
a lot in nature any way you have an
outlet really but they can be really
difficult to see the way you visualize
the them is by suspending particles in
the fluid kind of like a smoke ring
which I will beautifully demonstrate in
this next clip these are fun to look at
but incredibly difficult to see without
high-tech equipment or an airzuka which
was surprisingly hard to get hold of so
this is getting easier moving away from
vortices and turbulence imagine a very
very laminar flow a flow that is so
neatly layered that each layer lies on
top of one another nearly touching so
they can move one way in the other
without interacting that heavily for
certain fluids the flow is actually able
to be undone this is best demonstrated
in a Taylor cuet flow which is a
cylinder moving inside of a static
cylinder with fluid contained between
the two if we rewind and move back
exactly the way we moved it you get each
point back exactly to its original
starting position which just doesn't
happen with most flows you can't unpour
a glass of water now this definitely
feels like it breaks physics but it's
incredibly slow and a very scary
experiment to do in real life so I'm
going to give this a detail up next we
have what I'm calling complex fluids and
don't worry these aren't using imaginary
numbers complex fluids have inherent
properties to the fluid structure that
makes them behave quite strangely now we
start getting into the Sci-Fi stuff this
next one is perhaps one of the most
demonstrated phenomena in fluid dynamics
and all you need is cornstarch and water
when corn starch is fully suspended in
the water the new fluid has a rather
interesting property when left alone it
looks like any other liquid and if I
pour it gently it will move but when a
large force is applied something strange
happens under Force the fluid becomes
solid-like to put it in proper terms the
viscosity is now dependent on the forces
applied to the fluid and when the
viscosity depends on the force in this
way it's called a non-Newtonian fluid if
the force makes the fluid more viscous
like in this case we call the fluid
Shear thickening because it thickens
when it's sheared but in contrast is
also true if the force makes it more
runny then it's called a Shear thinning
fluid that's like ketchup it's the
reason why we shake the bottle to make
it runnier now this is incredibly cool
at first glance and quite fun to play
with but once you enter the realm of
complex fluids the phenomenon is so last
year even John tickle from Brainiac
already got it covered and that's a
throwback and a half it's definitely
cool enough to make the list and it does
deserve a place there but it's not that
exciting detail when an effect is first
documented with the words I can offer no
explanation for this Behavior you know
something really funky is about to
happen and that's exactly what Alan K
said in 1963 in his nature paper when he
first discovered the bouncing stream
effect which we now call the K effect
this happens when certain Shear thinning
fluids are released in a very thin
stream on a solid surface initially the
fluid builds up in a pile however every
once in a while something fantastic
happens the jet hits the liquid surface
and is rebounded off ricocheting upwards
in an unstable stream it was in 2006
that an explanation for this phenomenon
was discovered thanks to the use of
high-speed cameras it was observed that
actually thin layer of air is preventing
the jet from joining with the pile of
fluid causing it to bounce off just like
my bouncing droplets so for having a
surprising connection to my research and
being incredibly fun to experiment with
this is definitely getting a tier have
you seen the movie Lucy you know the one
with the people only using 10 of their
brains so they unlock the rest of
Scarlett Johansson's brain turning her
into this big black blob monster that's
what I always think of when I see this
next one stepping fully into the brain
of a Sci-Fi author this fluid is
wonderfully spooky and breaks all
perceived Notions of how fluids are
supposed to behave and to top it off
it's absolutely fascinating
mathematically too in the same way that
you can obtain non-Newtonian fluids
through suspending particles in a liquid
like water What If instead we suspend
tiny iron compounds in the fluid making
the whole fluid magnetic when it's fully
mixed in aptly named ferrofluids
interact with magnetic fields causing
these wonderful spiky shapes that just
don't seem like they could come from a
liquid the shape is formed due to the
fluid Trying to minimize the energy in
the system it doesn't want to be
stretched but it's still reacts to
magnetic fields this is such a cool
phenomenon but the constant reminders of
the very strange film do take it down a
little bit to Aid here imagine a train
with a whistle one of those old
steam-powered ones when the whistle
blows and it's sat in the station the
sound waves travel out at 330 meters per
second in all directions generating a
sound wave once the train starts moving
and the whistle blows the source of the
sound wave is also moving along with the
Train the train since it's old and
inefficient and slowly destroying the
planet knew I'd get some climate science
in there for you Simon it isn't moving
faster than the sound it produces so you
end up with this bunching of sound waves
in front of the train and a lag behind
but what if we go faster if instead we
were able to go faster than the speed of
sound then suddenly the source of the
sound is in front of the wave that it
just generated this causes a sonic boom
which not only causes an enormous amount
of energy but it sounds like thunder and
can cause all sorts of interesting
things to happen mathematically when we
approach the speed of sound suddenly air
starts acting as a pressable fluid which
can be incredibly fun to study but also
a little bit mad the maths of
compressible flows and supersonic flight
is so cool but personally I hate
thunderstorms and I hate when supersonic
jets go overhead and allow noises just
attached with the field are really
stressful so I'd have to move this down
to seat here final group of phenomena I
want to talk about involve multiple
fluids multi-layered flow is a massive
field of study as it can be used to
understand things from industrial
processes to how the layers of the
atmosphere interact with each other
whenever you have two different things
meeting there's always going to be some
interesting phenomena occurring draw a
wave did it look something like this
well it might look like a stylized
version of what we see on the ocean it's
actually not that far away from reality
these types of waves are generated by
what's called a Kelvin helmholtz
instability and it doesn't just happen
on the sea it can happen in clouds or in
any too fluid problem and yes there are
two fluids in the ocean the air does
count it happens when you have a system
where there's a lighter fluid it's
moving in One Direction directly on top
of a denser fluid in this case the air
is moving across the ocean the surface
between them is free to move and it
kills up in this wave pattern it's one
of my favorite phenomena to look at
because it's what we draw when we're a
kid and suddenly that's a real thing in
maths that is so fascinating this one
gets beatier take the previous system a
lighter fluid on top of a denser fluid
and flip it on its head you now have a
denser fluid sat on top of a lighter
fluid and it's no longer stable due to
gravity so the denser fluid is going to
want to move downwards through the
lighter fluid but it can't move all at
once so instead these plume-like shapes
form personally I think they look like
squids but the resulting interface is
absolutely gorgeous in certain
experiments and under certain conditions
you can see these fingers reaching
downwards however the motion quickly
becomes very very complicated and
turbulent detier the astute view will
notice that this next phenomenon is
actually a very specific type that I've
already shown you why does it get its
own category why does it get its own
ranking if the other one is more General
the answer to which is it's my video and
I can do what I want but also this one
looks cooler I just think it's neat so
take a Vortex ring and put it under
water now you have air moving in a
spiral pattern in a Taurus under the
water and you get a ring bubble and
that's exactly what I mean it to be it's
a bubble that's in the shape of a ring
the bubble is very unstable but the
faster it spins the more stable it
becomes the slower it moves the less
stable eventually breaking out into
typical bubbles that you see shout out
to the plateau raelian stability for
that one just really quickly deter
because it breaks my fun bubbles
arguably a ring bubble and a Vortex ring
are the same thing just with different
fluids but this one is so much cooler to
look at and there are loads of really
fun videos of divers beluga whales and
dolphins making them underwater so this
bums it up slightly to seat here so yeah
that's the list there were loads of
phenomena that I had to cut out but if
you want to hear me talking more about
fluid dynamics maths or anything in
general come see me over on Twitch at
cat does maths if you you want to let me
know exactly why and how I'm wrong with
my rankings though you can leave them in
in the comments down below for Simon to
deal with that's it for me I'll see you
in the next one or not
foreign